I think Fashion Week definitely has to
change for two reasons the first reason
is is the fact that indeed there's such
a huge lag between time lag between when
the clothes are shown and when they hit
the stores and you constantly hear
complaints quoted in the press for
instance from retailers saying everybody
saw pictures on style.com the day after
the Marc Jacobs show everybody came into
my store demanding this coat and I won't
be getting it for another three or four
months or another six months so I think
that given that fashion is such an
enormous business given that the
economic stakes are so high that that
time lag has to be addressed and Fashion
Week can no longer function in that way
for that reason indefinitely the second
thing that I think indicates that
Fashion Week has to change is something
really interesting that Alexander
McQueen did at Paris Fashion Week a few
weeks ago which is that he set up his
runway almost as if it were a computer
web site and he announced so it kind of
looked like each model was emerging from
this pixelated screen and her image went
back into infinity into this computer
and he announced that his idea will be
that ultimately people will be able to
order the clothing online while they're
watching the fashion show and this is a
function of a sort of a genius
application of modern technology at its
best and really eliminating the time lag
eliminating the weight enhancing his own
chances of selling more clothes and we
all know how impulse purchase is working
you see it you fall in love with it if
you could just hit a click you'd make a
lot of purchases that you might feel
guilty about later but I think that that
will be the wave of the future I think
there's no reason for designers not to
do that if the technology is there which
it seems to be then economically it
would only make sense for designers to
want people to be able to buy things
immediately and as copiously as possible
so I think in that sense to Fashion Week
may become much more interactive which I
think would be very exciting